Christiaan Pizza knows the weight of the
tennis courts he's been coming here
since his childhood he's always been an
enthusiastic tennis player but right now
he's doing his job he's shooting a film
about the Tennis Club hello my name is
kerstin pizza hello my name is Christian
feet sir I'm a freelance filmmaker I was
born in garlotte's eventually left it
for a while and I've now been back in my
hometown for a good year today I'm going
to take you on a walk through girl it's
Christian shows us that girl it's also
has its quirky side
like this building in the middle of a
row of restored buildings on over marked
the upper market square what's called
the bone house immediately stands out
Steven Banach better known as bone is
lord of the manor here he invites us to
have coffee it's like entering another
world when you come here physically
because you see so many things that
you've never seen before but also
intellectually you always find people to
talk to you can philosophize and discuss
and that's what I think is especially
great here it's an artistic and
inspiring place visitors are welcomed
here in this house which really does
seem to have fallen out of time
just stop by if the man of the house is
home you can stop in we go on to
Christian pizzas second recommendation
it's an industrial monument in which
beer is still produced today now it's
been in COF Damien lemon I'm now on the
grounds of the Lance corn brewery this
is a great spot here in gullets music
events are held here quite often and you
can also see how beer is made the
fermentation cellar is 12 meters down
it's one stop on the tour with brewery
guard vato Misha
here the beer is left to ferment much
longer than as usual elsewhere no visit
to a brewery would be complete without a
taste test the last recommendation takes
us to the girl it's City Limits
Christian comes here as often as he can
Lake Burt's turf is a former open-pit
lignite mine which has been flooded to
form an artificial lake the bats of
Isaiah is magnificent Lake bounced off
is my favorite place to unwind I like to
come in to swim barbecue and relax and
I'm standing where a village once stood
it was called dodge Aussie now all
that's left are ruins in the late 1980s
George asik had to make way for opencast
mining the deserted and dilapidated
buildings are a reminder of its fate
history and relaxation you'll find both
at Lake baird store
you